is this what you're doing tonight is
this what you're giving
you know I stay in you always and
forever I'm so proud that like I mean
you you've been a working actress for so
long and now like the masses we're all
getting to like bask in the glow how
does that feel
about time
I heard that about time it's like you
know you work and you work and you put
your head down and you think it's okay
because you love what you're doing and
you do giving your best and you're
working with people that you really
really enjoy and that they become like
family and all this is not what you
started off with and it's okay it's okay
but of course when you look at your
peers and you go like
and suddenly now to be able to be
getting
understanding what it feels like to
really be seen
it it does make a difference we throw
that word around so much to be seen But
there really is like a soul-soothing
asset we don't do it for the accolades I
know you don't but there is really
something to that when you when people
see you really see you you know when we
talk about uh representation yeah I mean
it's honestly it's about being included
inclusivity honestly being included and
allowed to sit with the rest of us right
and it's like I don't believe I've done
less so but I need the opportunity so
thank you thank you to the Daniels thank
you to a20 for you know thank you to the
people who believe this aging ordinary
woman should be given the chance to play
the superhero yes for character and you
are now you know one of the things that
I always say I stand about you is you
had told me you wear a lot of your own
jewelry wherever you go is this you
tonight tonight this is Mosaic okay no I
did that for crazy rich Asian yes you
did yes you did I was in awe of that
this is spectacular do you know how many
carrots you have on your neck I don't
care it's a lot
I see listen I counted them I told him
tell me tell me because I want to know
but I can dig it who is this dress he
scored Joe Armani I know he is exquisite
you look like a dream you really do can
we toast to you oh yeah okay
there you go to you and the toast is
it's about time
there we go
[Music]